As we mentioned, not only our immune system is compromised in regards to
stress, but we can also have problems with cardiovascular health. There are two
psychological risk factors that predict heart health. 1 of those is type A
personality and the other is anger. Those with type A personality or type A
behavior patterns respond to stressful situations or challenges with
impatience, hostility or anger. In addition, hostility and anger, which are our
emotional responses to stress, can cause an increase in blood pressure and
heart rate. Over an extended period of time, that can lead to coronary artery
disease. And then, that can actually lead to heart disease. The take-home
message here is how we respond to the stressful situation, by being angry or
hostile, may lead to heart disease. However, if we can reduce our stressful
response to the stressful situation, we actually may be able to avoid heart
disease. Now we're going to go back to Lauren and learn a little bit more about
heart disease and stress.